three garrett-smith the son of Oregon's
senator Gordon Smith and a depression
sufferer committed suicide at the age of
21 senator Smith tells a son's story and
his efforts at suicide prevention in the
new book remembering Garrett this talk
and book signing from the Deseret
bookstore in Leykis we go Oregon is 45
minutes thank you thank you and my
thanks to Deseret book for hosting this
event also to c-span if any of you are
political junkies like me you watch
c-span a lot well you're all on c-span
so our thanks to c-span for covering an
issue that obviously is an issue that
touches many many families an issue of
some national emergency and that is the
the great concern of the legislation
that bears my my son's name with
depression among youth in the staggering
rates of suicide among youth in writing
this book I frankly had many misgivings
not the least of which was the
painfulness of the topic of writing
about your own son's struggle with
learning disabilities he had a very high
IQ he had dyslexia all of which resulted
in his growing up with diminishing self
esteem writing about that was very hard
to do but it was also helpful for me to
do because I was able to work out not
only just his life story as it
intertwined with my career in in
business as a church bishop as a state
senator and later United States Senator
and all the dislocation that what that
means to children in families like that
but frankly children like Garrett
there's one or two fact there's one in
six people that have issues like
Garrett had and in writing about this my
motive was utterly non-political but
frankly just the genuine hope that out
of our the loss of our son we might be
able to turn a light on
in a few other homes where a son or
daughter is struggling and that they
might see signs that we missed and
thereby be able to get involved in this
in a way that they might say the life of
a child well that's what it's about not
just his life my career but it's also
about how difficult it is to pass
standalone legislation in the United
States governmental system but we
succeeded at that and it was one of
those issues I'm sure when you turn on
c-span you think do Republicans and
Democrats ever agree about anything
can't they ever be just Americans first
this was one of those issues not without
opposition and it's described in the
book how much opposition there was from
a few who just simply opposed the
government being involved in much of
anything outside of Defense but the way
in which this issue galvanized
Republicans and Democrats as Americans
recognizing a very real problem of
health in the American people it's a
story about them coming together it will
be renewing to you I hope when there is
described in this book the scene where
President Bush signed this legislation
there were equal numbers of Republicans
and Democrats there because depression
and mental illnesses don't register
Republican and Democrat there was Ted
Kennedy in George W Bush standing
together in common cause recognizing
that this is an American problem not a
partisan problem and so I hope that the
book also gives you some renewed sense
that in America there's a lot more that
brings us together
then tears us apart this happened to me
one of those issues I would also like to
tell you that I would not have been able
to do all I have in my life without my
children having an angel mother my wife
Sharon is right here and she has she's
put up with me for over 30 years now and
we've had quite a rollercoaster and a
lot more good than bad but as Sharon was
trained at in elementary education she's
an honors graduate at BYU she just was
there for Garrett every step of the way
and all the homework assignments that I
missed all the little league games I
missed all of the camp outs and fathers
and sons' outings that I wasn't able to
be - Sharon was there every step of the
way and so my my children did not lack
for good parenting but there's a lot of
self-examination in this let me just
simply say I tried very hard to be a
good dad but there are no perfect dads
there are no perfect moms there are no
perfect children and part of life six
struggle and and part of life's
experience is trying to succeed at that
which is our most important
responsibility and that's the work that
we do at home and that's another one of
the messages of of this book so I thank
you very much for coming for your
interest in this I'm honored by this
this big turnout and you're all on TV
now so why don't we go to questions and
if someone has a question there's a
c-span tendin who's going to put a mic
in front of in front of you before you
before you ask it who has the first
question yes right here
I've read so much and I'm so thankful to
both of you my question is and I haven't
read the entire book
how are your other children it's a great
question yeah and we you know one of the
things about our family Sharon and I and
again this is something that is when you
write a book like this that is so very
personal in nature you reveal a lot
about where you've been and what makes
you who you are
I I am the eighth of ten children I came
from a large family and when you're
number eight you learn how to fight for
the scraps Sharon Sharon was one of
three children and but we both came to
our marriage with a real desire to have
a large family and it didn't happen we
never had children naturally and so we
adopted our first two children through
the LDS social services which is a
wonderful experience I was a law clerk
in New Mexico for the New Mexico Supreme
Court when we finally got word after
seven years of marriage that we had a
little girl an infant to come and pick
up we named her Brittany and Smith and
she looked just like the cartoon
character Tweety Bird
big blue eyes bald head little blonde
curl on top and we just couldn't have
been happier with her we applied for a
second when we had moved Pendleton I had
decided I didn't like the practice of
law but I wanted to be in the food
processing business and very
unexpectedly and very suddenly we got a
call to pick up a little baby boy and
his name was Garrett Lee Smith when we
went to Spokane to pick up Garrett
beautiful little bear cub of a boy on
the way back to Pendleton Sharon I
wondered how would Brittany respond to
this little baby and when we went to
pick her up at her babysitter we
took Garrett and I knelt down I said
Brittany this is your new baby brother
and she looked at him and she said I
don't like it I don't want it and she
punched him in the nose so I wasn't a
good start some seven years later a
doctor in Pendleton Steven Lam called us
and he said I have a young woman I'm
treating who is an unwed mother and
would like to put her child up for
adoption and we were he want to know if
we were interested in when we pay the
hospital expenses and we were because
our experience in putting together an
adopted family had been wonderful and so
he came and we named him Morgan Spencer
Smith
he has flaming red hair he's our caboose
so your question is how do our children
respond to it it's it's been very
interesting Brittany and Garrett were
quite close in age and we're close
emotionally 20 months apart Morgan is 7
years younger and was very much the
little brother compared to Garrett but
both have you know have grieved
independent and what happens with grief
is it hits people differently and at
different times but I think both have
also found as Sharon and I have a sense
of faith the sense of family and an
abundance of wonderful memories of our
son to help you get through the grief
and to be grateful that we had Garrett
for 20 nearly 22 years so I think
they're both doing fine but I think they
grieve differently than Sharon and I
Brittany is 25 27 I always turn to my
wife any date that's in that book is
from her memory she's 25 married and
living in Provo Utah because she was
just 20 months apart and they were both
living in Utah
at the time just previous to Garrett's
death that she probably has had a little
bit more of a challenge getting through
this because she did not know that her
brother was having these issues and she
always felt like he was there for her
when she was going through her trials
and I think that it was a little bit
harder the younger one had been
separated because of a mission and him
my son career at being at college almost
three years and I'm hoping that we don't
see that play out later as any you know
issues that he hasn't addressed but
frankly the younger one has probably not
addressed or commented on much of it
though I think it was it was pretty
fearful for him when he heard the news
of it next question yes I also lost the
son to suicide actually about a year and
a half before Garrett was also bipolar
who was also severely dyslexic and very
high IQ so many of similarities I come
from I'm from a Catholic family of nine
children tor adopted and there was never
any difference between the adopted ones
and the and the biological kids I am
really close to all of them and I found
I kind of wondered a few guys have found
it all I found some friends and even
some family members that are it's kind
of like the elephant in the room they
are a little bit nervous even about
being around us or around me necessarily
I think because my grief is so much on
my shirt sleeve and I talk very openly
about it and but that's how I've gotten
through it I have five other children
I had five boys and then a girl and I
think what gave me the the most hope in
the very beginning was that she came to
me that night and said mommy please
don't cry so hard because now Ricky's
not sad anymore and because he loved
with us because he was close he was 20
and everybody lived in the same house
all my other kids suffered in a way I
didn't even realize until after he was
gone and what you know I want to know is
did you guys have a long struggle with
this suicide attempts or ideation as our
son did he struggled many times
attempted and and stuff frankly no we
did not know until probably the last
year that we had a serious problem our
hands our son was what you would think
of the boy next door he played on the
sports teams he pumped a gas at the big
gas station in the summer and he always
had a really a happy countenance about
him and I think that that was one of the
things that was so frightening to the
people in the community his school
counselors because obviously they were
working with him on a very close basis
him in as much as he had a learning
disability and their fear of what where
did we drop the ball because we didn't
know frankly Garrett did have a suicide
attempt before his attempt that well his
when he was successful at suicide and we
didn't find out about these attempts
until afterwards unfortunately a
roommate knew of attempt in February and
thought that it was just a call for help
and so he did not say anything and he
tried to cut his arm and I had seen it
and asked him what it was in the summer
just months before he took his life and
he said he'd had a mountain biking
accident and being that it wasn't at a
wrist or anything that I I just believed
him on what he had said though we did
know in those in the last year that we
had a serious problem and and he did go
for help but I think that we just didn't
catch it early enough one of the things
that I hope
besides this helping my husband I think
get through a very difficult time I'm
hoping that as people read this that
they'll share it and and people will
understand that mental health problems
are much more common than what you it
would ever imagine not all problems with
people
having depression are in in any way
scary or outward behavior that you would
know you have a serious issue going on
there are many people who quietly handle
this burden of depression and because
they feel that there's a lot of shame
that goes with it or perhaps their
parents if they find out feel that
there's a stigma that somehow it
indicates that they have you know been
poor parents don't go and get the help
that they need and so I think by us
trying to be outright honest about our
problem that we had that we are hoping
that we can remove the stigma and
encourage each of you to reach out for
those who need help and make sure it's
there for them and not to make people
feel embarrassed if they have a family
member that's struggling with this
because it could be like any other
disease and this was a wonderful young
man and he he just was a great son and
we we love him very much and we're
hoping that as he looks down from the
heavens this day that that he will feel
that this work is something to help
others yeah I don't know how to add to
that except just to say that one of the
messages of the book is designed to say
you know as public people we're gonna
reveal the worst private tragedy of our
lives and and do it in a way that has
absolutely no political implication as
in our hearts but to give parents
license to understand that there's more
to just taking your child to get a
physical a vaccination a dental checkup
an eye checkup how about a mental health
checkup these things can be determined
scientifically and accurately and
confidentially and the information will
be to parent sufficient that they might
save their life of their child
these are things we didn't know but we
wish we had known and that's one of the
points to Gerrits laws and just one more
comment on her on her her comment she
was saying people don't know how to
respond to those in grief
let me just say there's no perfect way
but the best thing you can do to someone
who's lost a loved one whether it's the
suicide a death and war even a
grandmother who has lived a full life it
doesn't take much to help what it really
behooves all of us to put your arm
around them and say I'm sorry and I care
about you and you just won't them you
won't believe how much good that
expression does for the person in grief
and that's another of the messages of
the book this woman right here has had
her hand up in the gentleman in the back
and then I'll come to you yes where do
you get the help I have contacted heads
of OHSU I need a psychiatrist
desperately for my daughter she's very
ill and I can't get any help the
psychiatrists are few and far between
they're busy they're booked where do you
go to get a psychiatrist there are none
well that's a great question I don't
know in this city I know where I would
go in my community but there are mental
health professionals obviously there's
psychologists who can counsel with you
and there are psychiatrists who are
physicians who can prescribe drugs and
that's a whole different level of mental
health intervention frankly I would if
your daughter's in school I'd go to a
school counselor in a health clinic and
I'd say my daughter needs help get me to
someone who can help her on a
professional basis and I would simply
not stop until you found a medic please
get help I mean that is what we're we're
pleading with people don't regard the
signs of suicide as being anything but
deadly and serious
and those include talking about it loss
of interest in appearance giving away
your possessions addictions or being
drawn to a substance abuse of alcohol or
drugs all of these things high anxiety
impulsivity
these are all signals that we didn't
know but wish we had and don't take them
as anything except a very very serious
and seeing a therapist at school she you
actually appointed her to the Air Force
Academy
Jennifer Bentley you might have
remembered four years ago she ended up
going to Carnegie Mellon and I've just
been brought to my attention last month
it's been going on for three or four
years she said and now I'm desperately
trying to find help and I do know people
in this community medical community and
they say that in six years one doctor at
OHSU said there was only one
psychologist that psychiatrists that was
going through the system to train as a
psychiatrist there's a big big shortage
in the United States yes there is and
maybe my office can help you too if you
need some other leads
it's gentleman in the back been answered
right here this I'd really like to thank
you for coming here and speaking out
about this issue I know it's very
painful for you and it's it's it's such
an important issue by my daughter also
died in college from my suicide and and
the comment that I want to make is that
this is such a silent issue yeah and we
really have to make it public for
everyone it's silent because a lot of
times your children will not come to you
first will not tell you it's silent
because they will perhaps go to a friend
who thinks they can help and will tell
know what nobody else who is a
professional that can help them we also
have a problem with our medical
community our medical community is
silent on this issue they talk about
suicide in general but any any kid over
the age of 18 and a lot of these issues
come up when kids go off to college the
doctors even if it's a life and death
matter are so afraid of the
restrictions in the HIPAA law that they
will not tell family members my daughter
attempted suicide there was every
indication she was a threat to herself
the doctors let her go from the hospital
they didn't treat her
they didn't contact the college
Counseling Center they didn't tell me
and a month later she died again from
suicide and one of the problems is that
these the doctors hide behind this
excuse that their hands are tied they
can't tell parents so I recommend a
strong recommendation by me is that if
any of you send your children off to at
college make sure that you go to the
mental health facility and make them
give you a form that and and make your
child since you're paying for her or his
education sign that form stating if
there's any if that child is seriously
injured in any way
whether it be depression and suicide or
anything else that you should be
notified as parents because otherwise
you will not they may be dying on the
operating table and they may not notify
you and if the kid has said I don't want
my parents to know period you will not
know you will not even be able to find
out where your child is and what
facility so we have to quit this site
everybody has to start talking about
this schools - schools will not touch
this issue in a general sense they'll
only speak about it after a child has
died you know it to your point I mean
again what we now know is what you
learned and though if there is any
single point in my right I never thought
I'd write a book and I never thought I
would be identified with this issue I
can count on one hand the numbers of
days I think I've been depressed but
what we learned is the truth of what you
just said and we again hope that as
public people by being out front on this
we can shine a light on it bring it
bring it out of the shadows help people
to have license to do something about it
and in frame
we get the resources behind these these
screening programs and the intervention
programs it'll save a lot of life and
some people say well people die from
lots of reasons some of the greatest
people on earth have been manic
depressives Meriweather Lewis 200 years
ago discovered the Pacific Ocean he was
a manic-depressive he eventually took
his own life
Abraham Lincoln was a manic-depressive
these are usually are extremely
intelligent people we can keep them with
us
they will confer tremendous benefit upon
society Winston Churchill was a
manic-depressive and so it behooves all
of us to deal with this openly and
honestly and without stereotype without
stigmatizing and it is truly again as
legitimate as physical health issues I
think one of the things that she
mentioned College is such a dangerous
time it's the second largest killer in
colleges I was shocked this morning when
I read the article in the Deseret News
that the you know the college where my
son was the same year they had eight
suicides at that college and I just
thought that's amazing and that you know
that we have not only ourselves that has
this great pain but seven other families
that are suffering and one of the things
that the Garrett Lee Smith Memorial Act
does is provides money for colleges and
universities and some of the I think we
had what at least three or four grants
that were given here in this day and in
Oregon and it's to build information
centers at colleges so that we can catch
these kids when they're very vulnerable
it's the first time that many of them
are out without the safety net of their
friends and their family and if they
have been dealing with mental health
issues and then have these extra
stressors on their life it can be a very
dangerous time of life
so I empathize with you and I know of
your loss right here this gentleman
thanks for coming Jordan
thanks for writing the book I'm dr.
McGregor retired I was not a
psychiatrist but I'd like to ask you
were there any incidents as through this
whole thing where the medical profession
was involved it's a great question the
answer is yes the week before he took
his life and bottom line we his roommate
wonderful friend lifelong friend of
Garrett's had told us before the
arriving of the summer break that he was
deeply worried about Garrett we then
went to see Garrett and were shocked at
his his appearance he had gained a lot
of weight he wasn't shaving he seemed
uninterested in himself anymore
his countenance was dark and to make a
long story short we said to him Garrett
how can we reconnect you with a happy
boy that we raised and he said take me
back to England England is where he
spent his Mormon mission and so we
dropped our August plans and headed with
him to to England where he showed us the
areas he'd worked in and it was it was
amazing to see the radical change in his
moods he was very high and then we would
drive away from one of the places he'd
served he would literally curl up into a
fetal position unable to speak with us
just I don't feel well I can't talk you
know just let me be quiet and then the
last night it was very obvious he told
us he his mental anguish was so great
that he felt he would take his life at
that point I said Garrett we have to get
you to a hospital we have to get some
professional how he was seeing a
psychologist he made it very clear he
would break out of any Hospital he would
not be committed and
but Sharon was able to get him to say he
would see a psychiatrist
we got him an appointment he went to the
psychiatrist who gave him antidepressant
medication sleeping pills to regularize
his sleeping patterns and we thought we
were doing what we were supposed to but
it was not obviously in time you
accidentally said one week before he
actually took his life in September he
started taking medicine from a general
practitioner the spring before after his
first suicide attempt that we did not
know about he at that time in February
said I think I'm ready to get some help
before that we had recommended it but he
had not want to do it but he did not
want to go to a doctor he just wanted
the GP that he had been going to to
provide him with the prescription so
starting from February he was on
antidepressants starting in May he said
he was ready to go for some mental
health counseling and so he met with a
psychologist and it wasn't until about
two weeks or maybe a week before his
death that he actually from the
psychologist referral got into a
psychiatrist it was very difficult as
someone said to get in there are not a
lot of psychiatrists in it he had
recommended it in late July but our
first appointment was just before
Garrett's death but to be honest with
you the psychiatrist said this young man
came in and he did not divulge any of
these problems to him and so I don't
blame the doctor at all but the
psychiatrist did change his medicine to
a more potent type apparently we don't
know whether he took it and my friend
sitting here my daughter-in-law had both
been in Pendleton for many many years
and we just moved to the valley and I
don't know how many places Linda lives
but anyway we just wanted to come see
you today and I want to say I lived in
Pendleton about 60 years before coming
back to Portland and Sharon and Gordon
lived we lived on the hill and they
lived up there you know and we could see
their home and every once in a while
look out and I wanted to say something
and one of the things that I remember
about is have what Gordon and Sharon
were wonderful parent excuse me were
wonderful parents and you need never
worry about your kids because one night
I looked out the window and here was
this cute little redhead running down
the street after his dad who was going
down the hill and everything was going
down and he was so intent upon getting
close up to his dad that I went out and
said why don't you just stop here a
minute and we'll take care of you until
somebody comes to like backup looking
for you and so thank you for letting us
being here today and I'd like to
introduce Linden levy Carter my son
oldest son's wife we like to think we'd
like to thank Senator Smith and his
lovely wife Sharon for taking the time
to share the experiences they had and
what this book is about and we'd also
like to thank him for writing this book
about Garrett that had to have been a
very difficult thing at this time we are
going to take the opportunity to have
senator Smith sign some books some of
you will be filmed on c-span if you
don't want that experience you can wait
back but if you want your two seconds of
fame go ahead
come up we'll just have him up here at
the table we would like to keep this
orderly so please form a line going this
way how are you darling good who do I
make it to to Jessica that a great name
you know why Jessica brother is bipolar
so we struggle with it every day but she
just had a really good friend who's
taking the lives so I hope you'll find
some help in ok- Anna Lee it's a tanned
and led what work yeah grey yeah she's a
bath this week
my family lives in Provo that's okay
your kids are there going to school well
they are what's your mom give mom a big
hug for me thank you so much thank you
thanks for coming hey how are you
you're Joshua yeah I took a guess I read
the sign thanks I just want to let you
know how much I respect to you and think
what you do thank you I appreciate your
friends call you Josh yeah I shortened
it up but I like it long well Joshua was
a great biblical name yes I liked it a
lot live up to it okay okay how are you
I did actually struggle for you yeah
you get the help you need yeah Oh Jim
well it's - my mom Rita - Rita she
wishes that work RIT a yeah well you get
the help they need okay we need to hear
yeah okay I haven't actually read all
day yeah my mom Sarina Mike
well III think there'll be some stuff in
here to help you
thanks buddy my name is Keith okay Oh a
few years ago do I make it to both of
you Keith in
to Keith and Betsy in actually office I
1 DC in two months did you do that
you're doing that I'm doing it you're
doing I actually got an email from your
office today well when we get enough
notice where we love to help
constituents get in the museum yeah
absolutely
here we go
Thanks it's the least second day hard to
do we think good hopefully people
understand it better now who can I make
it to
how are you hard to do who can I make it
what would you like me to write I'm a
loving father and man
I'm going to go way back anything else
now I'll just finish it from there okay
there you go this one's for me okay
Laurie Lau ah right yeah I felt hey you
are
oh hi how are you good my name is Jesse
Jesse music Stanford Jessica it does
yeah but nobody's ever told you
Jessica's well it's a good name how do
you spell your Jessie J es SI e okay
thanks so much for being here today
really important issue writing about it
something to the heart
don't show your students in a much
better place well that's our faith happy
that you're even the good boy see them
inside that you know yeah thank you guys
how are you fine thank you just for my
son okay his name he gets to be an
intern for you and watching ABC this
summer dusty so don't tell my golden lab
his name does it's a good name
he's experienced Ida
he said byu-idaho right now in this
graduation
there's my clothes
I appreciate this you're welcome thanks
for buying it
hope you enjoy it oh I've read it this
is my cubby
no hit it twice whimpering okay take
care of
take care kar am no I appreciate it very
much
where's dusty gonna stay when he's back
there is they all that ranged uh well he
has a family so no it's not a ranger
this is only arranged for 60 students
his wife's having a baby in a few weeks
so Toby Cameron is writing a friend
well that'll be great and especially to
work with you yeah well it'll be our our
pleasure and privilege oh yeah how are
you know all about this well I go home
but I was I knew I had to come here and
I knew I had to see I know you're a part
of it I met you several herbs well
today's date please okay Charles that's
me okay
last name
Charlie Norton Friday our channels and
why they are teaming on end and anything
you want to say that the finally yeah I
know what your people
thank you very much there you go
have a lovely life appreciate you
absolutely okay
you think we have a genetic situation
[Music]
well hold on - we're thinking of you in
the well we aren't for you - thank you
for sharing your bad Jordan about
Mitchell
hello bomb pleased to see you yeah last
time we were together I was playing golf
yeah well let that demon be more fun
right so make that to Bob yeah
I lost a young son-in-law to suicide
it's hard well not right it was very
hard for my daughter for the guilt that
she had well this is my wonderful
friends family Miller Sally and me we
have both lost our spouses and so we've
now joined together
you guys listen how are you yeah pretty
much no work really but life
good to see you snowy may accept a bit
more military term no I know it's very
informal place please - Brad yeah - Brad
yeah thank you for writing that out I
have a 19 year old son and he set it off
to University of Washington this year so
very interesting subject for me well you
hold on to I'm gonna work hard to do
that I think you saw a lot of reservist
who struggled what they didn't actually
we dealt with it belong and actually got
all the formal training all the little
tips against you were talking about huh
but it's a difficult thing because it
comes and goes and it's just hard for us
yeah tough subject appreciate that
almost consider sharing by the way I'm
going out and just introduce myself it
doesn't
yeah thank you sir
Thank You particular so fat okay big
crowd okay care
senator how are you are you I'm so good
and better that you're here thank you
for letting me break in the line a
minute I I have the impossible task of
filling his seat no one does it like he
did Earl many men have you home oh well
maybe for a friend Shirley okay Shirley
Ellie one Ellie why tennis PTT is
Overson are open
that's it thank you Karen you bet she
took her husband's place in the house it
was cooler than a plain gross
senator you're in this book your
handwriting is no no no marks him her
handwriting your mind both put us in the
Senate